today's topic so the nba finals just
finished and the uh los angeles leaguers
won
uh but what i wanted to talk about was
one of the story lines during the nba
finals
uh involving what i think is the one of
my favorite stories in sport history
ludens no it's a good story too though
yeah good for him i'm proud of that guy
um but it involves dwight howard now if
you aren't familiar with dwight howard
uh originally
i'll give you guys some backstory even
if you're not into sports you're gonna
like this so
dwight howard extremely talented young
man really tall big build good defensive
player
and he was drafted to orlando and he had
a great career
over there where he basically won
defensive player of the year was
renowned
and then he was moving to los angeles
which is one of the biggest franchises
alongside
um the celtics in nba history right like
they're the two biggest
sports franchise in nba when he moved
there
he was moving there to play alongside a
kobe bryant who's probably one of the
most
top five most famous basketball players
ever you know he died tragically in
january
but dwight howard went there to play
with him i think around 2013-12
and he came there as the golden boy he
was going to help kobe bryant win
another title it was going to be a super
team et cetera et cetera
but when he got there kobe bryant was
all about hard work and dedication
dwight howard came in there was a bit of
arrogance and i'm already good enough
and the team fell apart they were
eliminated in the first round
it was a huge letdown and the team got
blown up everyone got sent different
directions
and from that point kobe bryant and
white howard's relationship turned
terrible
really yeah it was bad he really they
didn't like each other right because he
chloe bright likes harvard yeah well he
blew it right and so
dwight became afterwards his career went
downhill every team he went with started
releasing him for the next five years he
kept getting thrown out from defensive
player of the year
and one of the top players this man used
to have the nickname superman
and now he was just getting bounced
everywhere it was becoming a tragic
story
and so this year he ended up rejoining
the lakers this is about
five years later and he joined up with
lebron
and basically they just kind of signed
him on a non-guaranteed guild said hey
you want to come play with us
we're going to give you the minimum from
getting paid the maximum when he was
there
he was getting paid the minimum and he
said it's non-guaranteed meaning we can
cut you at any point
which in nba is very rare
really it's not common to get a
non-guaranteed it's really just because
of what happened
yes and history he's out of history and
it's not been looking good so they took
a chance on him and he said i'm gonna
take my chances to come back
so they go through the season this is
this year and um
you know lakers are potential favorites
to win among couple other teams but it's
still looking uncertain
and then kobe bryant actually passes
away in a tragic helicopter crash
him and his daughter along with seven
other people died
uh the helicopter crashed in the hills
and um
it shook up pretty much the whole
sporting world as well as the world in
general this is before corona hit
and this invigorated the team
and dwight howard and the lakers after
this pandemic the playoffs resumed
and they made it all the way to the
finals and ended up winning and dwight
howard
won his first nba champion championship
i just wanted to play it man everybody
out there
don't ever give up you give up on your
dreams
get do it i swear just keep fighting
i swear
[Music]
so you know he talks about how hard it's
been for him um
and and getting to this point which is i
think what every player wants to get
this nba championship he's finally
gotten there
at the end on a minimum uh changed
mentality he's at
later years of his career where everyone
pretty much
wrote him off and it kind of was a
really good story of like redemption if
you will
you know someone who came in with talent
and arrogance
and then was humbled by reality but
still decided to persevere and learn
life's lessons
and kept going for it and kept going you
know a lot of people have too much ego
to
go back to some of the places that
insulted them or go back to some of the
places where
things didn't work out the way that they
wanted right especially when they had a
lower stature
and for him to go back there and to
overcome for me really touched me i
remember just being moved by because i'm
like
man this is a man who had to go through
a lot to get to this point and to see
him overcome all that and to succeed
um it was just nice and just understand
as well
where you failed yes you messed up yeah
you know i mean yeah
you have to put your ego aside a lot of
a lot of conflicts and in a lot of
conflicts that happen
you have to put your ego aside at some
point you have to okay what's going on
other than she's right or wrong
what's the bigger picture yep what was
the person trying to achieve you know
you have to put yourself in someone
else's shoes and also yeah put the ego
aside
yeah and sometimes well you know
it's really not you but sometimes you
have to look into yourself and do a lot
of social
searching to see what happened in that
in that situation but that's good that's
great
the thing that happened though it's it's
a cool story it's a good story it's a
great story it's a coolest story bro
but it's not true that it's gonna happen
to everybody it's not
everybody that's gonna have a second
chance nope you could believe in second
chance all you want it doesn't mean that
you're gonna be
a quarter a second chance yep so don't
mess up
and some of you are going to get a
second chance and still fail
but at least you got a shot yeah and all
that i'm trying to get at this
is give yourself a chance failing is
never the end
for anybody failing numerous times yo
you'll be
second chance third fourth fifth you'll
be shocked how many times
life will give you chances but it
doesn't mean that you have to call it
quits at any point
and if you don't call it quits i'm not
gonna guarantee that you're gonna
succeed but at least
you give yourself a chance and so
this is a story that we all love in our
movies this whole idea of redemption and
fixing your character and trying to be
better every day and you're seeing it in
real life that's why i enjoy sports
because
not just the story line but seeing
people at like the pinnacle of their
craft
competing i love that idea and it's just
great to see somebody persevere through
all these doubts and to come out on the
other side victorious it's just
it's uh it makes you get a feeling of
like i can
undo the wrongs in my life as well even
if it's on more minor scale so
i just want to share that with you guys
and uh yeah is there anything you want
to add on this kind of time
no so yeah that's pretty much it for
today's topic tell us what you guys
think
uh are there any redemption arcs that
you'd like to see in your own life